à eddy et là ce soir il a envie de voir
céder mon papa doc je vous demande
d'accueillir teddy doc gynéco tu sais
que je t'aime beaucoup et une personne à
contacter la production pour nous
raconter une histoire qu'elle a eue avec
tours ouais moi oui avec toi elle nous a
contacté personne et je voulais
absolument de faire là la surprise ce
soir
est ce que le prénom de brigitte te dit
quelque chose au déjà il sait pas ce qu
il a fait graver leur nom
brigitte tu ne te rappelle pas brigitte
non je vais faire entrer brigitte qui
est avec nous ce soir et
[Applaudissements]
né à merci d'être là brigitte alors
est-ce que vous reconnaissez brigitte
[Rires]
alors oui vous faites dans laquelle vous
cassez alors je travaille dans une
maison d'édition d'accord ouais vous
habite à pas est ce que ça vous dit
quelque chose
là ça commence à m'intéresser pourquoi
répond à livron disent que l'espèce le
livre y vivent
ouais édition alors si je ne dis pas de
bêtises connaissez bien bruno oui
puisque vous avez eu une petite aventure
avec lui voilà c'est ça il ya 11 ans ya
onze ans cette histoire serait souvenu
excusez-moi fille très jolie en tout cas
oui
malok sans rigoler est-ce que vous
rappelez de brigitte non est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire quand vous avez
rencontré doc et ou en 2008 dans une
boîte de nuit parisienne chez castel ah
oui
ça commence ça commença à lui dire
quelques dates pour sait très bien ce
que c'est que cette histoire est ce que
ça vous dit quelque chose
castel oui non mais brigitte surtout
mais n'ont toujours pas alors comment ça
s'est passé c'est que vous pouvez nous
raconter pour le rafraîchir la mémoire
oui donc d'être des amis et ils avaient
été en train de boire de l'eau
certainement nombreux badauds
ah ben moi je pense du soda voilà du
soda et puis un ses amis qui est venu me
voir demandant si je voulais prendre un
verre donc oui j'ai fait la connaissance
de doc on a discuté littérature musique
ni clermont a bien accroché en fait
voilà je parle que foot ce teaser des
sports alors qu'est ce que ça vous dit
quelque chose ou pas non à la fin de la
soirée qu'est ce qui s'est passé parce
que c'était une surprise pour vous à la
base un ouais ouais
à la fin de la soirée c'est vrai que oui
c'est moi d'accord voilà même bien alors
j'ai proposé de venir prendre un verre
la maison et il attend et il a dit
chocolat
alors alors aller alors et donc oui et
donc quand on a passé la nuit ensemble
vous avez passé la nuit ensemble voilà
oui non mais dans le même lit vraiment
pas évident même si oui des bahamas
comment et la galoche
j'ai eu de la gueule ah oui mais si leur
sang le lendemain donc parce que vous
l'avez revue obama lendemain je suis
parti travailler j'ai laissé un petit
mot avec mon numéro de téléphone et ben
a heureusement il m'a jamais rappelé
voilà le goujat oui alors qu'est-ce que
tu te rappelles parce que je sais que
brillante tu nous en as tu une fête on
avait parlé à un thé potes ouais m'a dit
que tu regretté voilà ouais c'est
dépassé oui et que tu as envie de la
revoir c'est pour ça que vous été
surpris ce soir en fait je rigole de
peter j'étais très bien reconnu ça va
est-ce que l'on ait ce qu'est ce que
voulez vous faire un petit bisou quand
même parce que c'est un petit bisou
judaïsme
donc ça tu garde un bon souvenir de
brigitte ou pas parce que je sais que tu
en avais parlé c'est c'est qu'on a plein
de potes en commun qui m'a dit c'est
vrai que voilà il avait connu brigitte
et il avait envie de la revoir comme ça
même par amitié parce que voilà c est
est ce que ça te fait plaisir ça fait
super plaisir shirt au revoir on va
avoir un verre ensuite au café à côté
ensemble
[Rires]
alors alors brigitte elle est très
contente vraiment de voir ce soir
voyez depuis bon donc c'était y accoster
à 10 ans il ya onze ans à 11 ans garçons
et et des contente de voir doc parce que
depuis tu a refait sa vie ou pas non je
suis toujours célibataire
mais déjà un petit garçon de 10 ans qui
s'appelle t dit quoi et si c'est pas le
fils de si je suis là ce soir c'est
vraiment pour une raison précise
roux et de cette nuit d'amour en fait
est né un petit garçon s'appelle teddy
soir je voudrais savoir si tu es prêt à
rencontrer à ton fils
j'ai dit oui je veux bien c'est vrai non
franchement c'est doc
tu te souviens de ces deux ça ou pas tu
te souviens de brigitte pas fait plaisir
mais grave je suis vraiment heureux
vraiment bah oui c'est au moins on a
quelque chose de ce soir était heureux
tu le savais pas du tout n'en doutez pas
du tout mais c'est une vanne vraiment de
nom mais protégez vous attendez à onze
on est sorti vraiment ensemble c'est que
doc le prends bien est ce que tu es
dyéla ce soir es10 et là ce soir il a
envie de voir
c'était mon papa doc je vous demande
d'accueillir teddy est là
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
au poulet voilà pour la caméra cachée de
daegu l'été en caméra cachée en direct
devra verser comment vous appelez rouaix
brigitte était formidable
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]